welcome to Jurassic Park five Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom is the fifth movie in the
Jurassic Park time linkable kind of I
feel like you have Jurassic Park one two
three and then a right drastic worlds
it's don't think so you see it as one
trilogy and another set of movies that's
aiming to be a trilogy or just one set
of five movies one is we're getting the
band back together because Isla Nublar
the island word Jurassic world is
located as a volcano that's gonna blow
up the entire island so it's a rescue
mission they got to go there and get
some of the dinosaurs off of it do they
come up with good reasons to bring Chris
Pratt and Bryce Dallas Howard back no
not really
hurts like you ran this facility no one
knows this island as well as you do
except one could argue the contractors
that put up the fence perimeter and
really constructed the park I feel like
they'd probably know the most about the
layout of the island but great now we
have her back and you you trained that
blue Velociraptor well you know what
you're back to really this movie's
broken up into two different storylines
comprised of three different acts I mean
every movie has three acts so that's ya
know kid what I liked about this movie
was the first act and the third act the
first act is essentially everything on
the island I really skeptical about that
stuff those are all right Islands
blowing up the sound of whatever this
way but really a lot of intense elements
were there did it all makes sense now
Chris Pratt keeping pace on foot with an
ash cloud from a volcano whatever but
damn it we got to see some destruction
that's fun and that's gonna come to
these Jurassic world movies for at this
point I see the Jurassic movies like the
predator movies the first ones the
classic I hit the nail in the head it
came out swinging and it completely
worked the second one is a legit attempt
at a sequel not as good as the first and
every sequel after I was like alright
well here's some stuff and whatever
sticks sticks the destruction of the
island aside there was some moments on
that island where there's a dinosaur and
you don't see it and then there's this
flash of light and it's there like the
backgrounds dark you see it flash a
light something's there and the person
still doesn't know what's going on then
another flash lights a little closer fun
monster movie stuff right there let me
get off the island to the second act and
that's what it slows down the movie to
sump pump the brakes for me it really
slammed on the brakes I was like all
right maniacal company doing maniacal
company villainous things I like a good
supervillain entity as much as the next
person but let's go but it slowed down
way too much for me the movie lost so
much momentum in the second act some
interesting things that were going on
but I can all
so read a news report of interesting
things different than entertainment that
flowed then the third act picked up
again and we have ourselves our monster
movie back it's a lot of stuff in the
third act that we've already seen in
other Jurassic Park movies it's a chase
sequence with this new dinosaur and our
heroes and a lot of it I felt like I saw
in Jurassic Park one when the two
Raptors were hunting people down even
have some shots some moments I'm like
that is straight up from that sequence
from the first movie point is between
doorknobs being opened up and a little
girl trying to close the door that
doesn't quite close as something's
running after her I seen it doesn't
change the fact that I was entertained
in the third act because that's what I
came for that's what the trailers set my
mind up for us with the first act
promise means with the third act
delivered there were actually a couple
of attempts of moral dilemma
I appreciate it didn't always stick the
landing but I appreciated that they
weren't there in fact I would argue this
Jurassic Park movie does best what other
Jurassic Park movies just talked about
which is the fact that these dinosaurs
are not monsters they're just animals
they're animals like lions like bears
like any other animal that we have in
our world
in our time I know Alan Grant has that
conversation with Lex in the first
Jurassic Park movie but actions speak
louder than words you can talk about it
or you can show it I felt like this
movie showed that premise very well Jeff
Goldblum's in the movie kind of means in
one scene not quite sure he actually
knew he was being filmed
you saw 90% of him in the movie from the
trailer so I mean don't hold your breath
a guy gets a paycheck either way so good
for him and I felt the supporting cast
they did nothing for me
there's one girl that's one dude they're
complete side characters and if they
weren't in the movie I don't feel like
the movie would be too different in fact
you could eliminate the support dude
entirely and then make the support girl
someone who's actually working with the
mercenaries which by the end of the
movie maybe she has a change of heart
and you just saved yourself some set-up
time because in the end Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom it wasn't great it wasn't
terrible it just was it doesn't capture
the magic of the first Jurassic Park
movie nor do I expect it to although
it's not quite the fulfilling monster
movie it wants to be because the second
act did drag it down a lot it's not
groundbreaking though it is ballsy that
they blew up the island but for Jurassic
world's fallen Kingdom I will say it's a
step down from the last Jurassic world
movie but still has enjoyment in it I'll
say it's pretty much a fun time
especially if you're drunk ya know it's
a party dinosaur or it's a Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom have you seen it
what did you think about it or what are
your Jurassic
he's ranked from best to worst whatever
they are whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]